there's no change to the lines outside
Spanish jobcentres 5.9 million people
were still looking for work in the third
quarter that's a dip of 73,000 but still
leave spain's jobless rate at almost
twenty-six percent one of the highest in
Europe for the unemployed this little
reason for optimism but it's nowhere
preserve its positive news but I don't
know how this will impact us I don't
think will even notice nobody took the
rules most analysts agree they say the
Spanish economy is growing too slowly to
create jobs and Madrid's austerity
measures are strangling the recovery I
don't see how that's going to make the
economy more competitive simply because
you're continuing with the ongoing
austerity I think that that's going to
make the situation worse for families in
Spain worse for small and medium
companies in Spain the government's
drastic cuts continue to stroke public
anger on Thursday hundreds of thousands
of students and teachers staged a strike
to protest against higher workloads for
teachers and increase student fees